I titled this and it was interesting to
see in the program there was another
presentation also had the word
reflections in the title and nothing to
do with image reflections it was all
about looking back and in my own case
I've been teaching with mathematic for
25 years and even before that I used SMP
and I actually gave a course in 1980 4 5
& 6 using SMP for numerical and
algebraic computing at my university so
it's actually even even longer than that
that I've been been using it so I'm
gonna be talking I think here to an
audience that agrees and understands
many of these views that I have come to
over the course of my teaching but I I
am always reminded by many of my
colleagues in physics that you know a
lot of people don't use Mathematica and
so you still have to convince them why
you should choose it as a tool so some
of my reflections are about that and so
the first comment I would make and even
though this is a historical comment by
the way can people at the back read that
is that too small okay good that many
the majority of courses around the world
I would say are still using chalk and
talk very traditional ways of teaching
and in courses on simulation modeling
computational physics courses the vast
majority of them still just stress the
the numerical techniques on which I am
no expert but what I much prefer my own
focus is more on analytic or hybrid
symbolic and numeric methods that's my
own research area which is what I also
try and communicate to students so my
views are upon reflecting about this is
that the standard approach which is
using some procedural language and that
may now be might be Java in some some
cases and in the astronomy and
astrophysics community Python is by
farther than the major language
my view as an educator is if you're
going to teach a language to a large
number of students and to give you an
idea what I'm talking about large how
our first year physics class has a
thousand students in it so it's it's
pretty large
they're not all physics majors they're
mostly engineers our second year class
has about 90 students that are majoring
in physics not all proceeded through
because they might be doing a second or
third major and our third year is about
70 and we use mathematical Wolfram
language in in all phases of that so I
guess my my view is that although
learning procedural programming is of
course very useful what I my personal
focus is more on explanation and those
that I really want to get into the
nitty-gritty and and and do lower level
coding and need that lower level coding
that's great but that's that's for
another course so another approach that
people use in their teaching called a
black box approach is that you have a
large range of specific applications
that you develop and I guess the the
demonstrations website is a very good
example of if you like and semi canjust
demonstrations which of course you can
unpack if you want and modify which is
very useful and my own approach for
example at the first-year level is to
use a lot of the demonstrations to get
across ideas rather than focusing on the
code one disadvantage of course if you
want students to become computationally
literate that you don't necessarily
learn a lot from the demonstrations you
might learn the fundamental concepts
which i think is the most important
thing but you don't learn programming or
computation if you use this sort of more
black box approach and the third
approach is what I have done
increasingly over the last 25 years is
an immersive approach and I particularly
have done this at the the third year of
our undergraduate
program where the entire course is given
using mathematical Wolfram language and
the students have to do everything in
that including their final exams so
their final exams in a lab three hours
submit and that's the way that it works
and it's very clear in that environment
how that is how effective that that can
be what I also like is during the
laboratory sessions that we run for this
as I'm walking around and one of the
ideas that I had fairly early on and it
was imposed on the judo computer
limitations was that we had a lab of 50
computers and we had a hundred students
we could run two sessions but I decided
particularly when they were starting on
on the system Mathematica to pair them
up for the this particular structural
limitation I had but it turned out to be
the best thing possible because the two
students working together achieved so
much more so much faster than one person
noting it out by themselves and so I
found that this accidental way of doing
it was brilliant and often I would just
be walking around behind them and
watching how they were attacking the
materials that I presented them to work
through and that's where I saw whether
what I was doing was worth succeeding or
failing not from the final solutions
that they were submitting but watching
the process of them struggling with
certain ideas working through them
seeing what worked what failed and you
know often what I thought was going to
be the fundamental limitation was
trivial to them and what I thought was
going to be really easy was they were
struggling for half an hour trying it to
nut something out so it was a for me a
great learning experience and over the
years I kept modifying the materials to
overcome many of those design errors in
in my work which I think God got better
and better and of course the other thing
was as we all know we're up to version
11 of Mathematica each time a new
version came out with new functionality
and I have to say I'm certainly not on
top of all the new functionality and not
if only some fraction of it but many of
the things that we had done in a certain
way can be done so much better
as I've said I'm a physicist I've been
teaching it for a long time one of the
questions we're using Mathematica but
you know what else is being used and as
I said in physics increasingly project
Jupiter and Python is being used and
it's a very good environment it came up
in John fossils talk but you know I
still see Mathematica is a better tool
to teach
I won't even open the last one I think
you would know the answers but from a
pedagogical principle I would just raise
something that often comes up in
computer-based mathematics
computer-based learning which is Bruner
book Berger pronounced something called
the white box black box principle and I
think this answers most of the
criticisms that people have of the use
of technology in education and the
basically the principle stated here is
that his view is that once you know how
to do something by hand a few times and
you understand the basic idea then you
can leave that to the computer
from that point on now my view is
slightly different to that but that's
that's a useful starting point
others have modified that I'll let you
read other views in this problem now
I've only got the early history of that
but you can turn that around you can try
different ways of teaching but I think
the fundamental principle by Bruno
answers many of the questions that
people have about the use of Mathematica
in in teaching
okay when when you're teaching you can
require students to learn mathematics
directly this is good you get to learn
the software but the downside is that
you have to be on top of it you've got
to spend quite a bit of time teaching
and your teaching assistants also have
to be on top of it I often approach and
I guess my own approach to learning it
is to hack to take somebody else's piece
of code modify it and so usually I give
a students a template and they have to
modify that to do something else and
that's their starting point and I think
they they rather than a blank notebook
which is a bit scary they start with
some framework to to work through I'm
one of the disappointing things possibly
including on some of the aspects that
I've done is many courses using computer
algebra and so in particularly
Mathematica the courses are still taking
a traditional textbook and teaching in a
traditional way and sometimes that's not
at all bad but in a system like
Mathematica there are so many different
approaches you could take the traps you
can actually revolutionize the teaching
that's a lot harder more challenging but
I think potentially more productive you
can also write your own demonstrations
you can use pre pre-written ones but my
focus has been certainly at the upper
undergraduate level is to get them using
the system directly
and may I just paused I'm not sure that
this schedule was for 30 minutes is that
correct some white people on the time
okay good that's what I've got no timing
here good okay so well that's what I
thought so too and so but they've given
me a time and that's showing 14 minutes
left
yeah I mean I said it was that's what it
was in my program and I'm a little
puzzled by that but anyway okay so my
goal is using teach at medica my my
course is based on problems as all
courses would be and I very few worked
example students work through them
themselves the advantages I think if
you're doing the problems yourself you
get a deeper understanding the concepts
you learn problem solving techniques and
by immersing them in this the the
students I don't have that much of a
focus on teaching the language and I
worked through Stevens elementary
introduction in four days when I was in
Japan this year I found an excellent
introduction it's almost like well that
I'll just give them that book and they
can work through that that's a good
starting point and if they've absorbed
that framework that that's a really good
starting point which we I think in in
many cases didn't have before but as I
said in my own course I have not focused
on many lectures on mathematic or I give
an overview one lecture that's a little
bit on programming high-level
programming in the language and then
we're straight into problem-solving with
with the course and this is a once a
semester long course we're essentially
weekly lectures of one hour and
laboratory sessions of about three hours
per week and that's the framework that
I've been working in in my presentation
there's there's notes - sorry links to
my my courses on on applied maths and
computational physics the applied maths
was at a second year undergraduate level
and the computational physics was at our
second G
and a third year there's two courses
there so I've got links to those I've
sort of mentioned this already but I
have not implemented any automatic
marking and you know Stephen showed in
his presentation some nice MOOC tools
and I think if I was going to redo
things that would be the way I would
like to do it where the student
solutions were automatically interpreted
and marked against a template and I
think that would be a more powerful way
of redoing what I've done but I'm
somebody who did was an ambition enough
ambitious enough or had the time to try
and develop a tool like that and it's
taken many years before I think the
technology is matured to the point where
where that tool is now robust and
straightforward so I think that that
would be an exciting thing to have
automate the marking automate the
feedback as much as possible one obvious
thing though compared to normal
assignments is that when the students
submit a notebook to me there's two
things one is I can rerun it the second
thing is I can I can annotate it and
return it to them and that's a real nice
exchange way of doing things so that's
that's what I find useful one of the
other points I mean this is obvious to
everybody here I'm sure but is that the
students can show graphically
numerically symbolically visually that
their answer to a problem is feasible
and that's something that I strongly
encourage that when they get an answer
whether it's direct from mathematic or a
derived answer within Mathematica that
they don't just return the answer they
have to verify and justify that and
there are many ways to cross-check
results within the system and that's one
of the true powers of it I have
mentioned sorry yeah yeah
I do it's a complete it's a very guided
thing if you if you download those I
won't do it now but yes it's a it's very
much a template-based thing where it's a
step by step thing and one of the issues
and particularly for the exam if you're
going to have a question that relies
that the answer one path feeds into the
next part I give them a whole bunch of
check points where even if they haven't
got that out they they've got the check
point where they can start from this
point and so assuming your answer was
this and often once they see the check
point they go back and they think that's
what I was doing wrong there and they
they can go back and revise and so many
of them I mean it's it's sort of hints
to improve the solutions but yes it's a
very much template based thing you know
as I said the materials are there to
download and welcome to have a look at
them you see you'll see very much it's a
structured format that they work through
I think the goal was in that three hours
that they'd be submitting at the end of
it yes but we had some flexibility about
that and and but our goal was we're not
trying to discourage outside learning
but I think the point is that you can
you can spend too much time on things
and other point was there some of the
students were spending too much time I
mean I thought it's great they were
fascinated they were loving it other
lecturers were starting to complain to
me saying stop giving them so much time
to work on this because it's impacting
on the other courses that they should be
doing so yeah we ended up restricting
the time yeah so as I said the I've also
got links to the exam for the second
year applied maths and the I think I've
actually given the links to my solutions
to those exam but there were lots of
student solutions and perhaps it would
have been better to give a good student
solution to those people see I think the
again another obvious point in the past
and this has got better with future
versions of Mathematica the student
experimentation is what
I want and that's what I actually saw in
the computational labs as I was walking
around that students were trying out
different approaches to solving it and
very often with a couple of things I
found firstly those students that had
not done a procedural language before
often embrace Mathematica much better I
suspect many people had the same
experience and also sometimes they would
come up with an alternative way of doing
it and I go that's actually far better
than my solution so sometimes the and I
would always acknowledge them but I'd
steal their solution and say here's the
solution from student Joe Bloggs from
last year it's a beautiful solution to
this problem and I found that you know
really encouraging and I see Eric's here
so actually I tell them that there's a
there's a bunch of really useful tools
and you would all be aware of those but
in particularly physics and applied
maths obviously the function side but
also the deal and F there's library
mathematical functions is really useful
when one of the embarrassing things I
see there is academics do not in the
digital library of mathematical
functions they they're still quoting
abramowitz and stegun rather than the
digital library which is the updated
version of this and has so many
advantages using it's not perfect and I
would like to have seen a closer
integration with Wolfram technologies
there and I know a bit of the story
behind that but anyway it's definitely
something I can make use of in addition
obviously the function site which is a
fantastic resource the demonstrations
and so on so again my point there is I'm
somewhat lazy I like to steal the best
of these resources and I'm often looking
in the demonstration so in fact I have
to say I was looking there this morning
for something
Michael Trott did a reasonable very good
conformal mapping app but what I wanted
was actually a simple one and I looked
through all of the ones there and I
can't actually find a simple one that I
wanted to use later in today's
demonstration so I guess I'm going to
have to write one but that's that's a
separate story ok so just a few examples
and some of these are historically they
go back a long time and some are
much newer this one was a problem that I
set in
let me just read the data there was the
discovery of a variation in the timing
of a particular pulsar and the reason
for this timing variation wasn't that
the pulsar itself was changing its
period but what was happening is that
the Pulsar was orbited by a heavy planet
and so the the pulsar was sometimes
moving closer to earth sometimes moving
away from the earth on our line of sight
and so that the signal there was a delay
in a time variation in the signal and
this was the first proof that there were
planets outside our solar system there
were all but bodies orbiting other
science but well in this case it was a
pulsar so the so what I got the students
to do was import the data I contacted I
think it's Alex wall scan who was one of
the Penn State University one of the
discovers this in 1994 I think I'm
getting the students to do so I got the
data immediately from him and I didn't
do it back then because you couldn't but
later it was updated importing directly
from a URL rather than you know sending
a data file and I try and encourage
students I mean the cloud has replaced
this to a large extent but the point was
don't save files on your computer save
them on the internet and so your
notebook immediately becomes completely
portable everybody else on the planet
can use the same notebook whereas if you
have a file you've got to distribute the
files as well so you you know you import
the data and this is the structure of
the data of course we have other things
we can do now but this is it so the
second column is the decimal time in
years and I'm not sure what all the
other columns but one was the delay in
milliseconds I just mentioned here of
course you can use it as a data set now
by the way semantic import just doesn't
work on this I don't know why I've got I
think it's a bug report to find out but
you know so this is a better
way a modern way of doing it in
Mathematica now so again these new tools
come and I have to keep changing what I
was doing because there's better ways of
doing it and so another one I did this
differently previously but now we use
time series to to analyze that data and
so we we visualize the residuals there
we can plot time series now and this is
what you see for the millisecond
variations in this pulsar now the four
physicists the natural thing to think of
is I've got some timing variations I'm
looking for periodicity Fourier obvious
the problem is the sampling is not
uniform now you could resample but there
are issues in doing so and the answer is
how do you fit functions to this and so
the the approach to do this spectral
analysis which I teach the students is
essentially and this was explained to me
my colleague is if you're trying to
observe that the frequencies of some
signal use an idea of resonance so if
you've got a black box it's making some
noise and you've got another speaker
that's listening to it
you you you tune your speaker and you
and you listen for the resonances when
there's you know strong feedback or
strong coupling between the systems so
the solution is to use linear
least-squares for one frequency and once
you do that you can determine something
called the spectral energy which is this
this constant so that's the the physics
there which I get students to do so
essentially what we can just do is do a
fit to our time series for a sinusoidal
variation and again if we plot that this
is what we see and it is clear that
there are two very strong periods there
there may be some others and indeed the
conclusion is this is this pulsar is
essentially being orbited by at least
two planets but possibly more and that's
the conclusion and you can read off the
the periods about 23 days and
30-something days the next part of the
analysis which I got the students to do
is compute the regression for this using
a nonlinear model now so our nonlinear
model is a superposition of two
sinusoids and if you try and run this
there's many parameters without a good
starting guess at least for the
frequencies this will just runs forever
but if you give it from that graph the
the maxima points you immediately get a
good fit and your verification is quite
beautiful and this is the point the
students immediately could see that
their answer made sense and then you
could go further and subtract this off
and see whether there's still a periodic
variation left is there a third planet
and Alex well scan did this and found a
third third planet orbiting as well so
that's the first example an old an old
one but I think the students were
excited because they were taking data
that had been released that year and
we've resulted in the nature paper and
they were redoing the analysis already
and I that was that was good next topic
is complex functions I it's not that
robust but just to do to tie here's a
thing for doing a complex plot of a
function this isn't it's not a function
within Mathematica but why not do do it
so just generalize plot to to do this to
show a plot so because they're meeting
in their third year complex functions
such as gamma Zeta and they want a tool
to visualize them so these these phase
sort of diagrams are quite nice and so
they can see the poles and the structure
of the gamma function and the other one
which I'm Paulie Gee's that I didn't
switch that off
you know the the next one here is a very
famous one the Riemann zeta function
when I explain to the students who
mostly a physics majors rather math
majors that you know there's a
million-dollar prize if you can prove
that the zeros of this function or why
they're non-trivial ones or why along
one line the Riemann hypothesis so I
have a little bit to say about that as
another example that I gave my students
to work through later but so the
plotting is quite nice it's very nice
and I gets the motivator they can see
their functions in their math courses
okay
I teach atomic and molecular physics
part of the course is there you know the
trivial example which you not completely
trivial by the example where you have
things like
hide that there there's better colored
diagrams of this but I just had a table
layout of the spherical harmonics and
you can do much more than I have done
here but s P and D orbitals just as an
example but one of the papers I did was
on visualization of atomic orbitals and
the point here is this is already just
too complex first to type by hand but
secondly to to visualize and so this is
for a coherent ly excited F state atom
the charge density for it yet fairly
complicated yet you know you have all
those parameters in there and you know
you can immediately visualize what's
going on and so the students are not in
one sense they they're doing some
problems on these excited F state things
in the third year of their quantum
mechanics and so actually being able to
get some feeling for them is is really
useful so that was a another sort of
teaching example I think Euler angles
and I see Dave wood offs here I haven't
seen doubt for years Dave educated me a
bit about the Euler parameterization we
talked about all angles but you know
we've got rotation matrices built in now
so this changed the way I did things
quite earlier they weren't there
originally and then even better we've
got you know transformation functions so
and we've got also just mentioned
function composition shorthand so for
physicists this is a nice way of putting
things together but none of that is
powerful but what is interesting is that
when you when you visualize this you can
see the very simply the effect of what
the Euler angle parameterization is and
changing it and so the students
immediately found that very useful
that's just another teaching example
just as a side I don't teach chemistry
but one of the one of the points is that
when you have the freeform input you can
do things like balanced equations like
this which are I think highly
non-trivial and the most the chemists
I've shown this type of example to go
while I juice would be do is ChemDraw
can plot or whatever it is to do this
it's a much nice
a way of doing it and I could see not my
area but it would be nice if these
electronic chemistry lab notebooks
physics electronic lab notebooks have
reserved a framework in Mathematica to
build them more easily okay this is apps
I'll just show the the demonstration I
had a Saudi Arabian student doing a PhD
Baha Rafa and we were working on quantum
transport in nanowires so he did my my
courses first and this is part of his
PhD thesis his PhD thesis was very short
partly because instead of doing pages of
diagrams he would just he had it was
enough submitted as a notebook I don't
know whether that's the first having a
PhD that was actually as a notebook but
it was examined in that fashion and the
examiners could see the validity of what
he was doing by actually having not a
period that you could get a PDF of it
static version but you had this
interactive electronic document as a PhD
thesis which I thought was interesting
and his you know this is one where in
these quantum nanowires
you have a war of long thin wire
nanometer scale and you can vary
impurities and doping you then this and
you're looking at electron transport
through those and you know this is as I
said one of the things from the thesis
where it's it's solving the the quantum
tunneling problem through that and you
it was was robust and simple to to
develop so my point was he developed
that after doing the courses that I've
done so he absorbed the necessary tools
to build something like this quite
quickly this is perhaps physicists deal
with Legendre equation a lot one of the
fundamental ones what we have to do we
can of course use dissolve to do this on
just the same time and in traditional
form we we get the Legendre functions
which is nice but there's another way of
solving this or this is if you do it is
initial-value problem firstly this is
nice where you show that as you change
the parameter in that where I'm changing
in continuously which is sometimes the
case in physics that we need how that
behaves it's a simple thing but perhaps
this is a little more interesting is
that if you wanted to solve that de one
way is to iteratively do it via
integration so here I'm taking the
differential equation here and
essentially double integrating it and
I'm using a coercion series expansion
there to do this and the students could
generate this and the solutions
including the parameters you know up to
any order it's it's straightforward and
that I thought was quite a useful way of
analyzing the problem which they because
they were using series methods as well
in the courses the pretty much the the
last I think it's the last example I
want to show you the last last example
was using the fast Fourier transform to
do contour integrals because in there by
the third year level of their maths
they're doing complex function theory
they are relating it to their physics
topics such as scattering and they've
got to understand and start doing
contour integrals and the relationship
between there are many ways of doing
this but relationship between the FFT
and certain types of contour integrals
is that if you have a circular contour
centered on the origin if you are doing
let's say a contour integral of this
type and I'll explain mention where this
comfort or if you're doing your contour
interval this type it reduces
essentially to just a one dimensional
integral around that circle where
theater is running between Norton to PI
and I've done this for the unit contour
and the point is that these integrals
here are essentially link there to
mathworld these are just the fourier co
efficient
right so the point is that if you sample
the function around this circular
contour uniformly the fft of that gives
you the contour integral of in fact all
of the moments of the I'm here looking
at the logarithmic derivative of this
function and the the reason is that if
you if you have the power if n is 1 you
you get the argument principle you're
essentially counting the number of roots
within the contour but this gives you
all the moments of that as well so
here's an application to the zeta
function and as i said that's one of the
topics that they deal in the fourth if
you symmetrize the zeta function that's
done in there number theory course for
them you can just show that indeed once
you've done that that full simplify
fails if i put that as an equation but
if i put as a ratio it works i think
that's correct or it did the last time i
tried it so this is the fully symmetric
version of the zeta function so you've
removed what the called the trivial
roots of it the point is this has a very
simple product representation but let me
just in this was something many of you
will recall and no jerry kuiper one of
the original Mathematica developers who
unfortunate was killed in a bicycling
accident but he wrote a paper in 1992
which was using Mathematica and
basically under the this complex
transforms that goes to one over said
all of the roots if they lie on the
critical line they are mapped to a unit
circle centered on z equals one under
the riemann hypothesis but if it's if
they're off the critical line it's still
mapped to two circles just not the unit
circle and and here's an example of that
where it doesn't look like a circle
because the aspect ratio but i needed to
do that otherwise it fills the whole
screen the black curve there is the unit
circle centered on set equals one the
green dots are the zeros of the riemann
zeta function and this is the first one
the second one
third one as you're moving up in the
imaginary plane and sort of as a limit
point there that these so the point is
that if once you've done this reciprocal
mapping you can compute all of these
spectral Zita sums the sums of all of
the routes and to do this essentially
what you need are the moments of the
these contour integrals and so they're
dealing with these contour integrals and
the point is actually it seems like this
would be a hard job to do but actually
computing the integrand you essentially
just define the so I'm defining the one
over said transform of the modified
cedar function taking the logarithmic
derivative of it multiplied both said
squared I won't explain why you do that
and evaluating it on the unit circle and
if you do that you get closed form but
involving these derivatives and the key
thing is that if you sample so if I'm
sampling I'm using that function I'm
sampling it uniformly I have to here's
this tiny offset as if there's a
singular point there and if I do high
precision arithmetic on this what I end
up getting are it's a it's a very very
fast process I'm getting very accurate
values of all of the moments all of
those zero sums of the roots and going
back to Jerry Kuiper's paper if you do
is a slightly modified function if you
can prove that all of these particular
moments are positive you prove the
Riemann hypothesis so it's an
alternative way of doing it
anyway the students work through that
and they also well just to relate it
there firstly we've done this using a
contour integral but instead you can
just use a series expansion about the
origin Mathematica does this and gives
you closed-form expressions which get
rather complicated as you go up to high
levels and if you if you check the
values of the first few of those they
agree perfectly with Fourier
coefficients so it's a very fast way to
get all of the moments for this because
if you do it using the series method
it's
it's arbitrary-precision accurate but
much much slower way of doing it so
that's an aside but the the basic idea
here I've applied it to the zero
function with this basic idea for many
of these contour integrals you can turn
them into Fourier problems which is a
lot easier and a lot faster to do ok so
that's the the the topics that I was
going to cover just as what what do I
see from the students that have done
these courses and as a set of my
university in first year they're doing
an introductory physics course and
they're seeing Mathematica via
demonstrations in the second year
they're doing some labs both in applied
maths and introductory sort of
computational physics and in third year
they're doing much bigger projects and
one year the the assessment accessible
outcome of those projects was to produce
a demonstration and have it submitted so
that was and accepted and so that that
was actually quite exciting to them
essentially they were being published
through that mechanism so what do I see
I see that the students have improved
model building and certainly improved
problem-solving capabilities they learn
a range of computational methods and
different tools and techniques some of
them that are quite advanced and they
get to apply those early on and I think
by the end of it it's certainly in the
third year they have a pretty solid
understanding of the strengths and
weaknesses and the capabilities of
Mathematica in their research my
feedback I mean this is I've been
analyzing it for as I said about 20
years the feedback yes these response to
questions they become more confident yes
they've learned how to apply principles
in new situations yes the contents been
challenging doing this science has been
valuable you know all right great things
but the other side of it I would say is
that this is particularly this point it
requires a lot of effort on my part to
develop materials work through them and
get them in a robust state that they can
deal with and I would say for the
students and this gets going back to an
earlier question is
that they end up spending a lot lot more
time on it first to learn the system and
two to work through the assignments and
some if if they say an engineer may
engineering major as well as a physics
major say takes too much at that time
others say it's it's time well spent so
I might I guess my attitude is I can't
make everyone happy so I'm going to do
it the way I'd like to it but you know
it and I really truly believe that you
there is no way of making everybody
happy in what you do so I think it's
worthwhile that they learn a tool widely
used by scientists they certainly find
the interactivity manipulate was a
revolution they're all of my courses
once manipulate come out and basically
had to say I'm gonna rewrite all this
this is a much better way of doing so
many of the things that were done before
just on the demonstrations I'll just
I've got it open here this was an
example what one of the students
prepared he's now a PhD student where
you can draw a random graph and what he
is doing is doing something called pt
symmetric quantum walks that's for
parity and time inversion most people
think in physics still think that the
Hamiltonian has to be commissioned to
get real eigenvalues this isn't true and
it's been known Carl bender highlighted
that back in the 1990s but it's it's
been known for a long time that's not
what you need PT which is parody and
time inversion is enough to to get real
eigenvalues and so for the question that
that this is Josh Isaac one of my former
students it's working on this is can you
[Music]
what's the question here can you
implement PT symmetric Hamiltonians on a
quantum computer when one's built so how
would the algorithm how would you make
this they work and so he basically built
this this out which i think is pretty
neat it's a directed grass and you can
see whether something pseudo hermitian
or whether it can actually be
implemented in one of the computers but
the the ability to draw these freeform
that's probably a different note sort of
thing there I'll just clear that I mean
he has a number of canned ones here and
you can say well what happens if I join
up extra the notes and see and that's no
longer sudo a mission it and it's
basically nonunitary so it's not a valid
quantum process and you can't implement
it in the quantum computer so these are
the sort of things that they're
developing and I quite like this is an
example of the freeform Wow well the
easy drawing of the graphs that you were
doing and you know picking you know six
circle cycle graph and seeing whether
it's a possible PC symmetric candidate
so once he developed this in fact for
the research group came the tool all of
them are using for trying out some of
their ideas he's actually got an
extended version in which you can import
and modify much much larger grass for
actually working with but this small
scale demonstration was just to to show
it so I the question I guess I often get
asked is you know what have your
students learnt in the course and have
they benefited from it and one of the
answers is well those certainly that go
on to higher studies I know that they
have because I see them implementing
really very interesting things using the
system you know in a very nicely
structured elegant way I guess I don't
need to say any of those these things
because these are all one I will
emphasize here not this one first I just
mentioned the we can give these user
interfaces manipulate is absolutely
essential for this curated data is
useful but the one question the one
topic I'll just highlight that I've used
in the the third-year exam one of the
processes I set for the exam is I'd give
them a current research paper from J
furs or phys Rev and the the goal of
their three-hour exam is I'd pick these
carefully but I'd say implement as much
of that paper as you can in three hours
right using Mathematica and it works I
mean I picked the papers so I know that
it's they have enough of the
understanding of the
the basics and that's what's covered in
the curriculum but they can actually
reimplemented
a lot of what's done in these papers
very quickly so what I'm saying is you
can ask research-based exam questions
rather than canned trivial problems if
you have an environment where you've
taught them a good tool and you can ask
them real questions and so I'd say
that's one of the features of my course
that I'm proudest of is the fact you can
do things like this but it's the tool
Mathematica and Wolfram language that's
enabled that so that's that's the the
end of my talk and I've let some some
time for questions